I go hang out he be a war Chinese
parents really focus a lot on their kids
they plays a lot of hope and a lot of
investment into their kids there's
anything that can make their kids more
competitive and stand out from the crowd
what has the penis turn on Tommy sure
made Joel June alien ham and cheese
omelet rizzardo sugar maple Azusa where
children are both investments and
cherished dumplings in a Confucian
society a child's accomplishments is a
manifestation of the nobility of an
entire family so people would sell their
souls I speak only a little bit with
exaggeration to get their kids into
Harvard
Chinese parens care a lot about the
status and the perception of a place
in order to make sure their kids end up
at the Ivy League's or Oxford or
Cambridge they track back they're like
okay now let's start at high school the
little IBD so call it Exeter and over
Deerfield Choate
Arceus needs to go there in order to be
competitive enough globally oh don't
talk about that why don't you want to
talk about Andover
I'm already hung over is an excellent
prep school did you apply to Andover no
I don't dare I don't dare to put apply
it yeah yo you have to have a lot of
extra curriculum and you have to be
really really outstanding
we're so sensitive I'm Daisy Leo and I'm
50 years old now calm down Daisy you
know my mom used to be just a normal
person and will not have money to
support me to study abroad but she
started her own business
after we become wealthy I think I have
more chances to do new things so Daisy
where are you going
California Stephenson school boarding
school is very hot right now especially
in America all my students the mothers
they remember me because I went to
Exeter they're looking for first a
better education more opportunities and
then when you do come back to China if
you do then you have a better chance of
getting the best jobs my mother wants me
to learn how American surround their
business and take it and come back to
China and use it in her business or my
own business even the party officials
kids want to go to college in America
because America will equip them with the
tools both educational and social to
succeed back in China actually I've got
several offers from schools but I chose
Stephenson school
is that's my favorite school and it can
fulfill my needs there they have a field
forward back riding and a golf course
Golf is from America isn't it